[Música]
a fechar o ted não é uma
responsabilidade fácil né
vocês devem estar cansados ou não deve
tá ansiosos eufóricos ou não também
então como eu faço a menor idéia de como
vocês estão se sentindo eu posso
compartilhar como eu estou me sentindo
eu estou muito feliz está fazendo ted
talk em curitiba é a minha terceira
experiência e fazer em curitiba fazer
dentro de casa é uma sensação
maravilhosa porque a gente ver se
funciona
então a pergunta que eu quero fazer para
vocês antes de entrar em detalhes e
falar um pouco sobre o produto falar
sobre a solução é falar um pouco sobre
uma coisa que eu gosto muito de fazer né
marina eu acho muito em conta a história
da marinha enteada tá só pra
compartilhar o a intimidade com todos
vocês é será que nós estamos preparados
para trocar a nossa única vaca leiteira
por três feijões mágicos que de repente
surge do nada disponíveis para nós
transformar em algo sensacional algo
inédito algo muito mais vantajoso do que
nós temos do que a própria vaquinha
inteira bom porque estou citando como
exemplo porque de todas as minhas
qualidades e defeitos
duas delas eu sei que eu sou muito bom
eu sou um ótimo paciente e eu sou um
ótimo pai e como pai e sendo um ótimo
pai
uma coisa que eu aprendi a fazer foi
contar histórias e de todas as histórias
que eu acho que são sensacionais a
prestar atenção na minha vida
toda a do joão eo pé de feijão parece
que tem uma posição muito forte no que
acontece hoje
então se vocês me permitirem deixou de
contar lá rapidinho né te serve pra tudo
serve serve para contar uma história
também do joão eo pé de feijão
vocês devem conhecer ela bom primeiro
que a história de joão eo pé de feijão
não é nem um pouco politicamente correta
porque a gente pensar na o conceito
correto é mais ou menos assim
joão foi enganado logo cresceu o feijão
maggi que ele foi enganado o gigante
então se a gente olhar diretamente nesse
sentido nós estamos contando uma
história politicamente inadequada aos
nossos filhos
por isso que eu prefiro a versão de 1807
que conta mais alguns detalhes sobre o
que joão fez durante essa eufórica
aventura
a primeira parte é que ele era medíocre
e miserável
ele vive numa família é tão pobre e tão
perdedora que a única coisa que eles
tinham era uma vaquinha leiteira que já
havia sido roubado por um parente
neodi havia sido roubado de um parente
era a única opção que eles tinham
naquele momento de transformar aquilo em
dinheiro de transformar aquilo em algum
tipo de sucesso e por não saber
empreender e por não saber melhorar algo
e por estar sozinha a mãe de joão fala
pra ele pega estava aqui e leva até a
cidade venda e traga para nós
mantimentos para este inverno que o
restante deus nos dará chico buarque
usou uma frase bem parecida também né
e se deus não der e se deus não é bom
joão no meio do caminho foi interceptado
por um velho senhor astuto falador
dinâmico que tinha três feijões mágicos
joão olhou pra que ele falou a raça é o
que deus está dando é eu posso pegar
isso levar pra casa são feijões mágicos
imagine o que há de ser né porque se
deus não der a de ser algo com estes
feijões mágicos isso é proveniente isso
é inteligente joão aos seus nove anos de
idade
dez anos oito anos de idade não sei a
idade mais mágica
existem na vida são os 89 anos de idade
eu com nove anos de idade eu queria
construir robôs que eu pudesse entrar
dentro eu só não entra dentro deles mas
eu também sei que tenho construído bons
robôs
eles têm dado bons resultados quando
joão chega em casa com três feijões
mágicos para sua mãe
vocês conseguem imaginar o tamanho da
frustração dela com aquilo porque não
dava pra fazer um cozimento sequer com
aqueles feijões a raiva dela por
distração dela foi tão grande que o
autor dessa versão da história de 1807
diz que ela remessa os feijões pela
janela e expulso joão de casa
existe até uma certa lógica nisso né
até uma certa permissividade que isso
aconteça
entretanto joão não perdeu a fé dele
joão tinha plena certeza que aqueles
regiões eram mágicos e ele ficou
cultivando aqueles regiões por semanas
por semanas a fé de joão foi constante
até que um dia num momento específico
quando se cruzou as atmosferas
necessárias
segundo essa versão da história e um
raio caiu em cima de onde estavam os
feijões cresceu um pé de feijão mágico
enorme que cruzou os céus que cruzou as
mulheres
o sucesso era mágico funcionou era
aquilo que ele queria
bom a outra parte da missão continua
você já imaginou você subir num pé de
feijão que não tem escada não tem
elevador não tem facilitações urbana
soho tecnológicas que cruza as nuvens
ele com certeza precisou de muita
dedicação e continua tendo fé e
superando certa parte do seu medo porque
eu não sei o que tinha lá em cima quando
joão chega lá em cima tudo é gigante
tudo é maior do que ele tudo é
monstruosamente assustador
as formigas são maiores do que ele as
aranhas são maiores do que ele a
vegetação é maior do que ele e ele se
achava medíocre quando estava naquela
vila pequena ele descobriu que era ser
medíocre o que era ser impotente
ele pisou naquela terra diferente quando
joão cruz aquele jardim curto mas que
para ele era de semanas de trabalho sem
poder se alimentar direito sem precisar
sem contar com o conforto da casa o
abraço da mãe ou quem sabe até a raiva
da própria mãe tudo aquilo que estava
acontecendo ele chega numa porta gigante
que pra escalar também levou alguns dias
para conseguir quando ele cruza a porta
ele descobre que do outro lado não tem
nada mais nada menos do que um gigante
um gigante que come as suas vítimas e
que os convencia a subir naquilo é um
homem cuja esposa está trancada num
copinho e do lado dela tem uma fadinha
do lado dela tem um dragãozinho lado
dele o ipo unicórnio porque é isso que
essa criatura faz convence os tolos a
chegar até ele e ele os devora eu gosto
muito dessa versão da história porque
joão simplesmente ele decide libertar
todas essas criaturas e no que ele faz
isso o gigante vai atrás dele
ele também corre né que pede feijão
abaixo o gigante corre atrás de corte no
pé de feijão eu estou adiantando a
história aqui que apague todos já
conhecem mas o que eu acho mais
interessante é que quando o gigante cai
na terra e ele morre nesta queda toda a
região onde ficou dominada pelo corpo
gigantesco passa a ser uma das maiores
produtoras de feijão que aquela
localidade já pode ter ea partir daquele
momento joão passa a ter a prosperidade
junto com sua família porque postando
esse exemplo para vocês porque eu passei
por algo muito parecido com essa
história eu vivo um pouco dessa história
ainda para quem não conhece a minha
história para quem não sabe porque eu
estou fazendo o ted
o fato de eu ser um ótimo pai é o que me
trouxe para cá
o fato de eu ser um pai é o que me
coloca hoje para falar na frente de
muitas pessoas
vários dias de fé
quando eu comecei o trabalho que eu vou
apresentar daqui a pouco pra vocês eu
não fazia a menor idéia se aquilo que eu
estava imaginando lucubrando funcionaria
não funcionaria a minha família se
decepcionou comigo a minha família os
meus pais e os meus irmãos são
decepcionado comigo até hoje porque
efetivamente eu passei por cima de
vários valores valores que eu aprendi
dentro de casa que era justamente
olhando para aquilo funcionário de uma
maneira ou outra eu tinha plena certeza
que eles feijões que aquela ideia que
aquele conceito que estava seguindo era
algo que levaria para algo muito maior
de onde estava quando eu olho para
aquilo e eu decido subi eu percebo que
sim eles eram mágicos é um caminho
perfeito e incondicional para chegar em
algum lugar eu precisei de muita coragem
porque não fazia a menor idéia do que
tinha do outro lado
aliás eu não fazia a menor idéia além de
para onde eu estava indo e quando a
gente está tentando falar de
empreendedorismo né mas só quando está
tentando falar dessas coisas parece que
tem que ter o rio sempre tudo pronto e o
meu problema é o seguinte olha eu tinha
dois grandes problemas
eu não fazia a menor idéia da área que
estava pisando e eu não sabia nem que eu
estava empreendendo
eu só sabia que eu precisava gerar
sustentabilidade de alguma maneira para
aquilo que estava construindo porque
senão ele não teria futuro não teria
êxito vários dias de força de vontade
porque tudo absolutamente tudo o que
tinha em volta de mim era maior do que
eu
as pessoas eram mais inteligentes que as
pessoas eram mais competentes do que eu
na área eles eram mais proprietários da
solução do que eu porque a única coisa
que eu era naquele momento eu era um
paciente
e sabe qual é a parte pior da história
que eu faço uma analogia eram vários
dias de terror porque o meu maior
inimigo aquilo que de verdade eu tinha
mais medo estava a poucos centímetros de
mim e se você não consegue imaginar o
que eu tô falando eu quero apresentar
para vocês
a pessoa responsável por um projeto
o que está salvando dez vidas por dia
laura fressato
é a minha filha mais velha
vocês sentiram angústia vocês sentirem
ansiedade quando o filho de vocês quando
o parente de vocês está com uma gripe ou
quando a sua criança precisa ser
vacinada levar uma única edição
vocês ficam ansiosas o angustiados
quando vocês precisam dar o medicamento
e aquilo provoca certo transtorno de
ansiedade nas suas crianças
a minha menina tinha 18 dias
ela ficou 18 dias comigo ela tinha 28
centímetros projeto na mão de vocês o
que quer 28 centímetros por favor do
projeto em 28 centímetros de onde vocês
ela precisou fazer um piquenique alguém
faz idéia do que é um pequim
alguém sabe o que é um pitching o pique
é uma interceção onde você tem que
colocar um cateter numa a horta para
poder dar nutrientes para o paciente tem
que projetar isso em 28 centímetros
quando isso aconteceu eles tiveram que
mobilizar laura
assim como você mobiliza uma pessoa um
adulto não porque ela oferece algum
risco mas por que era tão microscópico
que precisava fazer o recruta
profissionais fizeram era tão
microscópico que precisava de um
comportamento agressivo para que aquilo
acontecesse eu passei por isso por 18
dias e eu posso dizer para vocês hoje
que a laura com seus 440 gramas com seus
28 centímetros e com toda a vida que ela
me mostrou que é possível ter mesmo nas
piores condições que o ser humano possa
estar exposto mesmo nas piores condições
ela foi uma grande curitibana porque o
que ela me deu na sequência foi a
possibilidade de querer impactar de
verdade a vida de um bilhão de pessoas
usando tecnologia efficient assis
viveu e real tecnologia que funciona e
isso hoje está acontecendo em seis para
sete hospitais vamos instalar 17 o
hospital agora de forma estratégica as
pessoas pergunta pra mim assim jamais
porque só seis hospitais porque é
estratégico
eu não estou vendendo a laura para a
área de saúde
eu tô dando a laura para a área de saúde
e esses seis hospitais estratégicos hoje
nos últimos três anos permitiram que nós
pudéssemos conectar com o estado clínico
de um bi 1 milhão 250 mil pessoas
hoje o robô laura da alerta sobre sepse
e sobre deterioração clínica baseada em
memória proprietária ela não depende nem
mais do histórico do hospital ela não
depende nem mais o histórico dos
profissionais
sabe aquele gigante monstruoso fodástico
que estava descendo atrás
ele ficou tão pequeno tão medíocre hoje
que ele consegue dar oportunidade para a
gente a partir do mês que vem
dobrar a quantidade de hospitais porque
nós estamos conectados na santa casa de
porto alegre que tem sete hospitais na
sua instituição ea partir de maio desse
ano eu vou só dobrar só dobrar só dobrar
porque nós estamos com a tecnologia hoje
capaz dessa exponencial idade e é por
isso que eu estou muito feliz de fazer o
ted hoje eu estou muito feliz e está
falando em curitiba porque nós seguramos
essa informação para esse dia porque o
robô laura está salvando hoje 10 vidas
por dia
independente da atuação da equipe
independente do alerta ela avisa que dez
pessoas espírito de ajuda no mínimo e
essas dez pessoas são salvas então
alegria não tá sendo de só dizer que as
coisas estão funcionando eu e minha
equipe não é uma equipe grande
nós levamos todos os dias pra casa dez
vidas positivas
e pra quem que a gente precisa agradecer
isso para essa pequena guerreira e é pra
ela que eu gostaria que vocês batem
palmas
[Aplausos]
[Música]